Ok, Matt, I know blood cells are
important, especially the red blood cells, because
we hear about them all the time, but what exactly do blood cells do?
>> Well, red blood cells are one of the most populous cell types in your body,
because they carry out a very important function.
There's a very special molecule inside red blood cells
called hemoglobin that binds oxygen and carries it
to all the cracks and crevices in your
body. Its role is to actually go to
all these places and exchange oxygen for carbon dioxide.
It's the gas waste of our bodies. And even the shape. Everything about a red
blood cell is essentially tailored to help maximize
the efficiency of exchanging oxygen for carbon dioxide.
>> Wait. But then, what does that have
to do with blood type? Why does that matter?
>> That's a great question. Blood type doesn't
directly affect any oxygen consumption. But, on the
surface of red blood cells, like most cells
in your body, they're covered with different molecules
that determine the blood cell's type, as we
call it. This carbohydrate may or may not
be modified to have three different types. The
addition of an A antigen, the addition of a
B antigen, or no addition at all. And
whichever combination of these antigens you have is
called your blood type. Now the protein that
modifies the carbohydrate is an enzyme, a protein itself.
An enzyme is anything that catalyzes a biological reaction.
So if you look and see this enzyme adding the
A antigen, or the B antigen, or no antigen,
where do you think this enzyme, this protein, comes from?